yes thank you so much good afternoon to
all of you good to see you again uh
first of all i want to thank the hrvp
joseph burrell
you yuta and oliver vargali who is
remotely connected to us
for the excellent preparation and
cooperation to
get global gateway up and running
it's now that is a coincidence exactly
two years
that this commission is in office
and in the first two years we have very
much focused on accelerating the twin
transition here in europe the european
green deal and the digital
digitalization
you all know that we have invested and
we are investing massively
in the infrastructure but of course also
in skills
and therefore today
with this global gateway we are showing
that we now step outwards to support
around the world the investment in
infrastructure
that is necessary
for our partners we all know there is a
huge investment need out there
when it comes to global infrastructure
of course all countries need
a lot of investment in the real economy
to create jobs but also to increase or
to improve the livelihoods of their
citizens
and there is a second element that is so
important in this infrastructure that is
needed to be invested in
it is the kind of modern infrastructure
that holds the key
to tackle
the challenges we have today first of
all of course fighting climate change
but also the question of sustainable
development for developing countries
the question of global health security
it's a new big topic since two years now
almost two years and with that occurred
also the question of
resilient open reliable supply chains
now
when it comes to investment choices
they are currently relatively limited
and the few options that exist
too often come with a lot of small print
which includes big consequences
be it financially politically but often
also socially
and this is why we are convinced that
countries need trusted partners
trusted partners to design projects that
are sustainable
and that are of high quality
we want projects that are implemented
with a high level of transparency and
good governance
and quality
and in the very end these projects have
to lit to deliver on the ground
tangible results
that benefit the local communities and
the people in the respective countries
global gateway is this positive offer
global gateway is the european union's
plan or you may call it road map
for major investment in infrastructure
development around the world
we want to take a different approach
we want to show
that a democratic
value-driven approach
can deliver on the most pressing
challenges
we want to show that it can on one hand
meet no local needs
but also on the other hand tackle the
global challenges we have
and thus in a way also of course benefit
the european union
because global gateway is also about our
strategic interests around the world
it's a new strategic approach to
investment
global gateway will mobilize
300 billion euros until 2027
it will invest around the world
to support our priorities that is
the green and the digital transition
think for example of investment in clean
hydrogen we have partner countries that
have an abundance of renewable energy
think of wind or solar
to produce hydrogen which is of interest
for them as well as us
or think of underwater data cable
connecting to continents for example as
a project
globalgate we will also focus on
transport links
healthcare capacities i said at the
beginning that the global health
security is one of the big topics
but it will also support schools and
education systems because we know by
experience from our investment
at home here it's the investment in
infrastructure but also in skills
therefore global gateway will also
invest support schools and education
systems
we want to make global gateway a trusted
brand that stands out because of high
quality
reliable standards
and high level of transparency and good
governance
we are deeply convinced that this will
ensure
that the investment makes a real
difference on the ground
and this that this is done in a
sustainable way
to make all that happen we need to
deliver not only the strategic way but
at speed and at scale
and my final point is therefore an
implementation
first of all this is a team europe
approach so the european commission
with the member states and with the
european financial institutions
secondly to give it the scale that is
necessary we need to involve the private
sector
and this is not just about attracting
financial capital of course this is
important but with that we are also
attracting
technology
technology
and know-how capital that these business
sector private business sector can bring
along
and the third topic for implementation
is of course political leadership you
have to take it to the upper level
um therefore it is here anchored at the
highest political level
and we will bring it forward for example
the first test test case will be the
african union european union summit that
we will have in spring just to show
these are the first flagships we're
starting now bringing to this project
and making them happen
last but not least
we're not alone
we have like-minded partners that are
planning the same
i have hosted co-hosted together with
president biden at cop26 a meeting an
event
exactly on that topic
the americans call their initiative
build back better world
but we also aligning with our british
friends with clean green
so
it is for us important to make sure that
there is a different way to deliver
in this infrastructure globally
and to show
that mainly democracy value-driven
investments can deliver on the ground